I know she's here I felt her in that
dance i relieved it on mondays Dancing
with the Stars
Alexis rent paid tribute to her late
mother who died in 2014 after battling
cancer the model channeled her emotion
into a stunning contemporary routine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
breathtaking performance so emotional
how hard was it to revisit that time in
your life I I didn't think it was gonna
be that hard cuz I'm pretty open about
it in my normal life but it was hard it
was hard to go back to that place and it
was the emotions I was almost like
scared I was like I'm not gonna come out
because I'm talking about this and I'm
really bringing these emotions out for
this dance so I was a little scared and
I I was shaking before the dance
I just didn't know what's gonna happen
but I'm really happy that I was able to
release that pressure did you feel to
get her story right and it seems like
you guys like your partnership has grown
exponentially closer this week alone is
that accurate um you know there's so
much pressure just because I wanted to
make this moment so special for Alexis
and her mom I know she's watching down
and she's so proud of you but there's so
much trust that Alexis puts in me so I
feel like our connection and our
relationship was growing just because
we're just really open we thought with
each other and we're just you know we're
trusting in each other and it's I can
see that she trusts me completely so it
makes my job easier you know it's really
nice to have someone that trusts you
I know that your mom was such a fan of
Dancing with stars you said so many
times this was her favorite show do you
think she would just freak out over this
she would be sobbing she would be
sobbing and crying
and like though I just I wish I could
have that moment with her but I feel it
inside of me my sister was in the crowd
and after I finished I looked out to her
and I like we made eye contact and
there's a parts of her in us because
we're her reflection so I was able to
have that next week of course Trio week
what do you guys have in store who's
joining we got Maddie Ziegler announced
it right before we dance and that's
super exciting we're so excited for that
I feel like it's nice because unlike a
lot of other couples
Maddie's never been on the show before
this she's never competed on the show a
lot of other couples have past winners
or as finalists and it's nice to bring
someone new on the show and where you
have this new energy and they're so
similar but so different it's get back
one we're gonna each other yeah what
kind of dancer we're doing we're doing
the tango I'm really excited
[Music]